primera reparación para la familia de
georg floyd
un acuerdo civil por 27 millones de
dólares que pagara la ciudad de
minneapolis para resolver la demanda
civil de la familia contra el gobierno
local quiero dejar claro que el consejo
de la ciudad de mineápolis ha aprobado
de manera unánime la indemnización de 27
millones de dólares no ninguna cantidad
de dinero puede solucionar el intenso
dolor y trauma causado por la muerte de
georg floyd a su familia ni a la gente
de esta ciudad el asesinato de floyd en
mineápolis a manos de un policía el 25
de mayo de 2020 desató una oleada de
protestas en todo eeuu contra la
violencia policial que en el país se
ensaña especialmente contra las personas
afroamericanas más de nueve meses
después empiezan a llegar las
consecuencias
la familia de floyd aseguró que la
indemnización no parará su lucha por la
justicia understand that s slow
entiendan que esto no termina aquí los
policías deberán responder
si necesitan un recordatorio solo
piensen en el caso de georges floyd para
saber que si no hay cambios políticos si
no se arreglan las políticas actuales no
volverán a ver
make sure porque nos aseguraremos de que
las vidas negras y los valores negros
sean comprendidos libanés
el proceso judicial contra el policía
que agredió a floyd derek joven sigue
adelante está acusado de homicidio y
asesinato en segundo y tercer grado se
prevé que el juicio empiece el próximo
29 de marzo tras la selección del jurado
de ser condenado podría afrontar penas
de hasta 25 años de prisión